Cuál es la situación de Los afectados
justamente en estas zonas donde el
control lo tiene el régimen de vallar al
azar sancionado internacionalmente por
la guerra de más de una década tendría
razón el mandatario al decir que se ha
puesto lo político por encima de lo
humanitario
Bueno buenas tardes Valentina un gusto
estar acá la situación en las áreas
controladas por el régimen
al azar como decir bien es muy compleja
llega poca ayuda justamente por las
sanciones internacionales que vienen
siendo escaladas desde hace varios años
mucho antes de la guerra por varios
motivos incluyendo el apoyo terrorismo
el control del Líbano bueno
las sanciones de Estados Unidos son muy
complejas y no permiten prácticamente
ningún tipo de ayuda fácil a Siria y
controles burocráticos hay controles
financieros las de la Unión Europea son
más limitadas es por eso que hoy Italia
puede llevar un equipo médico a Damasco
para asistir a las víctimas Estados
Unidos recién el viernes pudo levantar
las sanciones
Para apoyar a Siria en este momento
difícil sin cambiar su posición sobre
Siria por 180 días a la vez Siria
permitió nuevos pasos fronterizos para
que llegue la ayuda a las áreas Rebeldes
ahora bien
respecto a tu pregunta si la política se
ha puesto en el lugar de la ayuda hay un
poco de eso de los dos lados Siria desde
el 2020 solamente permite un paso hacia
la zona Rebelde y quiere que todo el
tráfico de ayuda pase por el gobierno
sirio recién el viernes decidió dar Un
paso atrás y permitir más ayuda por la
presión internacional Estados Unidos y
solo propio y desde el viernes bastante
tarde permitió el flujo de ayuda y
restricto no hace falta permiso para
ayudar al gobierno sirio o al pueblo
sirio o a las ong en Siria
bueno Cuáles son las fuentes de ayuda o
de apoyo a los afectados porque vivimos
la llegada del cargamento proveniente de
Italia otro del grupo chilibaneses bola
Quién es más están del lado del Azar que
puedan colaborar
bueno esa pregunta es un poco más
compleja del lado del específicamente
del régimen está Rusia con mucho apoyo
en el consejo de seguridad de Naciones
Unidas está China en una capacidad un
poco más reducida porque Rusia tiene
apoyo militar está Irán y el ejército
Proxy de Irán que es también emiratos
árabes Unidos está haciendo un apoyo
sobre todo financiero muy fuerte al
gobierno ahora bien Además quienes
apoyan al pueblo sirio en áreas
controladas por el régimen está la Cruz
Roja Los cascos blancos y médicos Sin
fronteras
bueno Y también es importante Ya usted
lo estaba diciendo pero es importante
analizar la situación del lado de los
Rebeldes Naciones Unidas pidió un cese
el fuego inmediato en estas zonas a
pesar del terremoto y de la afectación
se siguen presentando combates
Sí en menor medida porque hay mucha más
atención mediática en toda la región
pero por ejemplo en el día de hoy Hace
unas horas nomás el estado islámico la
presencia que aún mantiene en Siria
realizó un ataque en áreas afectadas y
hizo lo que siempre hace que es ejecutar
civiles también
las fuerzas rusas
mercenarias apoyaron y avanzaron a
posiciones nuevas de que hasta hace poco
estaban atacando con
intenciones manifiestas de apoyo
humanitario pero no se van a ir de ahí
del área
del lado Rebelde es un poco más difícil
de discernir porque las comunicaciones
están caídas y
la el nivel de devastación no permite el
mismo nivel de operaciones y
coordinación